a faixa ea sandália assim ciro frente
recebeu gravar bola o que o meu deus eu
não acredito
o jazz eo funk noite se o treino faz
nada e outra ela existe ela vai te fazer
uma reação e ação e assunto é bots
pessoal aqui quem fala é dar que sejam
muito bem vindos já mais um vídeo e
alguns tragos aqui uma reação um trailer
do filme bright só estou a fazer um
vídeo com uma câmera de frente é cético
mas jogador tem 60 frente e eu tô aqui
testar a luz da corrida vettel só pra
ver se ela funciona bem e você consegue
entender melhor a minha pele inglesa
eu não sei fazer mais rápido sair bom
pessoal vamos rir juntos aqui o trailer
para a vossa cueca porque o site isso
vai estar muito bom que era preciso dos
fones folha não são de todos fomos para
lá
3221 o vasco começou já no campeonato
francês um medo o pânico faz é fredes
2.733 está contada uma história assim
observa novo
o fogo esta é se está a falar o que
temos sentido uma ventilação aqui o
princípio de uma nave especial houve ou
não esta não existe isso não acho que eu
acho que é ser amigo não era um anel e
não sei o que é isto
o botafogo que era que o novo neca olhou
gomi meu deus em bares festas enquanto
olha só como o pato brilhante está tudo
a sustentação roni não fred e esse é o
prêmio
boa tão bom a a a
esta nova imagem também em tom debochado
boone não sofrerem eu não sei quem é uma
pena que o poeta estranho nem está aqui
a sister boca chan a finatec fred sister
location não antes do não é tu é mais o
homem entrou num não quer sou eu agora
vou tentar amenizar este trailer porque
foi bem rápido e eu não consegui
perceber bem o que estava a passar 321
bairro após ataque ao frete de frades 12
caí aqui é o trecho e só pôde sequer ou
dois mas não é o trecho aqui é o quatro
e isso e agora é o 5 pela lapela impera
eu preciso perceber o que é que isto é
tudo isso dentro de uma cápsula
giratória 360° que é isto ontem que uma
das válvulas tem um botão tem que os
códigos têm que é bailarina o cargo nos
anima telefônica um dos nosso cinema
tronics é uma bailarina isso já
percebemos o caí anda lá pra frente
opel de coke é preciso nenhum
animatrônico para lá acho que por si o
que qualquer coisa nova
ó diploma caco não sei mas nunca visto o
bicho aqui ó
olha só para só então lá atrás de uma
bailarina é temos o fred o time o boni
não é este é o boni este é o freddie
esta é a bailarina que supostamente
agora é nova prata né
acho que uma coisa assim não sair é que
tem menu e as postagens posto mts sister
é o 15o título sister locais chan
olha só a cara dela
meu deus é um palhaço isso parece um
palhaço meu amigo scott cacau também
cacau conta ao se eu fizesse um novo
fato natty dread 5 num circo eu
simplesmente não vou chegar não do fat
freddy's sista colocation bom pessoal
quer fazer deixaram de estrelas no na
minha opinião acho que vai ser um jogo
não estávamos precisando agora de um
fanático fred 5 assustador pra
cometeu que vocês acharam os comentários
para receber também a vossa opinião
sobre este trailer se apercebeu que
alguma coisa escondida que eu não vi com
estreia alguma informação diga nos
comentários
eu quero saber também até a próxima